je viens ici qui est journaliste de
terrain qui a monté la presse en 2010
médias indépendants qui fournit des
images des manifestations à toute la
presse là vous allez pouvoir nous
éclairer sur ce qui est dit depuis le
début
sur ce que nous a dit olivier sur ce que
nous dit gregory joron qu'est ce que
vous dites là dessus
olivier et il nous a dit quelque chose
tout à l'heure qui a des policiers qui
passaient d'un camp à un autre
son téléphone sur lequel on lui on lui
mettez vous qui êtes sur le terrain
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter si
vous le voulez bien cyrille moi je vais
parler de mon domaine la presse bien sûr
puisque c'est là dessus que j'étais
invité de bien sûr notre part pour venir
dans cette émission
moi mes équipes nous sommes duris de
terrain ça fait trop trois ans que sur
le suit sur le terrain que du coup les
luttes sociales que je couvre des
événements heureux malheureux des manifs
qui se passe bien des manifs extrêmement
violente
nous sommes dans notre agence
régulièrement blessé nous avons des
blessés graves
nous ne nous plaignons jamais alors si
vous permettez je fais un petit
précision parce que je lis beaucoup de
ça sur les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup de gens me disent mais quand
vous êtes blessé faut pas vous plaindre
les journalistes vous aller au contact
vous allez au mieux des manifestations
c'est bien fait pour vous vous cherchez
non notre métier c'est de reporter ce
qui se passe dans l'eau potable ces
manifestations de montrer aux gens la
réalité d'un conflit social et peut-être
même d'un conflit social qui dégénère
parce que c'est une information
donc nous surtout que là nous nous
plaignons jamais de prendre des coups
d'avoir des blessés d'avoir des gars de
matériel et puis il ya un deuxième plan
le plan d'une répression qui ne devrait
pas exister
et cette répression c'est parfois ça
nous arrive mais il n'est pas question
de généraliser c'est sur un moment de
câbles lors d'une manifestation un
policier qui passe à côté de vous méfier
pas parce que c'est calme et à coups de
matraque sur votre caméra votre caméra
est morte
ça m'est arrivé ça et harris est arrivé
à tous mes collègues c'est arrivé
monsieur ça nous arrive malheureusement
de plus en plus fréquemment
oui il y a vraiment un problème un
problème en tout cas pour nous
journalistes
après me faire notre travail sur la voie
publique et qui est beaucoup plus
prégnant depuis quelques semaines on en
reparlera en raison de 7 2 se dote de
subissent donc nous avait parlé le souci
est que effectivement nos images peu
dérangé mais pour mme pour moi enfin
pour nous gens lisent de terrain le
problème il n'est pas policier brême et
des politiques rien moment il faut il
faut il faut dire les choses lorsque
l'on a je vais prendre deux trois
exemples si vous me autorisée lorsque
l'on à rémy buzine que les moineaux des
journées ce que je connais très bien
avec lesquels je travaille qui sont
menacés d'être mis en garde à vue
notamment le 17 le 17 novembre dernier à
l'assemblée nationale parce que le
policier un policier ou plusieurs
policiers vers 10 messieurs les
journalistes la loi s'applique à tout le
monde
vous dégagez vous êtes placé en garde à
vue c'est inadmissible oui c'est tout
même les cibles selon elle étaient à sa
jambe le jeu le journaliste doit être
protégé dans sa fonction mais je crois
que les fans d'abord personne ne dit la
verse personne ne sait pas ce qui se
passe sous le terme monsieur mouche non
mais moi je vous savez moi je vais pas
remettre en cause que vouliez de parts
par nature pas construction jeu j'ai
plus tendance à vous croire et si
effectivement il ya des circonstances
une atmosphère et un travail encore de
pacification de professionnalisation du
maintien de l'ordre évidemment qu'il
faut que ce travail se fasse et je crois
que le ministre de l'intérieur pour le
coup avec des paroles très plus à très
très très clair très cohérente sur la
formation sur les équipements sur la
déontologie sur il a parlé de renforcer
encore le lien entre la police et
l'homme et la population doute c'est
très clair moi ce que je dis c'est que
c'est symptomatique et c'est ce que j'ai
essayé d'exprimer auparavant d'une
société qui quand même aujourd'hui va
mal en vrai tout est filmé je viens même
ici on est des personnalités publiques
pour la plupart est ce que c'est normal
qu'on accepte que sur or ici on n'est
pas filmé il ya des matches où on a fini
par accepter les trucs complètement
dingue moi je suis moins populaire que
jamais je me fais insulter tous les
jours mais là c'est toujours menacé de
mort tous les jours je pense que vous
sais pas et sait pas on a fini par
accepter ça on a fini par trouver ça
normal
en vérité tout est filmé tout est filmé
tout le temps et c'est même peut-être un
problème que ce soit autant filmé et
parfois autant utilisé à des fins pour
nuire pour être toxique faillir c'est
aussi insultes société si vous êtes vous
dit quand je vous renvoie à l'image de
ce policier par terre avec la v3 black
blocks avec trois mecs qui filme ça
interroge à bord et un mec qui se fait
lyncher par terre
c'est redonner quoi avec ce soir ici ou
pas c'est inadmissible
là on parle même pas de position parle
d'un homme en détresse c'est j'aurais
dit la même chose évidemment si ça avait
été réglée par le pack police que sur la
mise et c'est dramatique
non